This is Melissa Carlton
At the age of 37.
She said, the way she said it was that Christ knocked her
to her knees and she trusted Christ.
And just a couple years ago,
but now in the last few weeks, God has just brought her
to a place of conviction to say, I've never been baptized.
I've never declared my faith publicly like that.
And so this is what we're doing today
and rejoicing with Melissa,
what he's done in her life over the years, thankful
for the opportunity to express that through baptism.
And so based on your profession of faith that you gave to us
and have talked with us over the last few weeks about I get
to baptize you in the name of the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
Church, would you pray with me?
Lord, I'm so thankful for these testimonies of
life transformation, that Lord,
you have done a work in Ryland and Melissa
and we get to see evidence of that every day and,
and this is an act declaring that to the world,
to the church that you have saved.
And so, Lord, I pray you continue
to grow them in their faith.
Grow them in the depth of their knowledge of you, their love
for you and their love for others.
As a response. Lord, this is your grace.
It's a picture of death to life spiritually.
And I pray for anyone out there who has never tasted
and seen that you are good, that you are the Savior,
that you are the one who can take life out of death,
who can bring beauty out of ashes.
These are evidences of that even today.
Work in those lives as evidence of these testimonies
that they've seen you.
I pray for others to see you as well.
Bless them, Lord, grow them. Help us as a church.
Help them grow in their faith. In Jesus name we pray. Amen.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Church, we love you.